today on the matt well show it's been
just a week since an anti-white racist
uh racist massacred six people and
injured dozens more to christmas parade
the media has already forgotten the
attack but we should not we'll talk
about that today also the robbery and
looting epidemic continues to grip our
cities there is a mostly unexplored
similarity between all these incidents
that we'll talk about today as well and
the dreaded omicron variant has everyone
in a panic or at least we are told that
we should panic over it is that reaction
warranted will discuss plus another
white woman is caught pretending to be a
minority and a gop congresswoman makes
an edgy joke about ilhan omar and then
commits her real sin by apologizing for
it we'll talk about all that and much
more today on the matt wall show
you know i'm not an expert in very many
things but one thing i know very well is
sitting i know how to i spend a lot of
time sitting i know something about
sitting and one thing i know about
sitting is you want to make sure that
your chair is very comfortable which is
why i am always very grateful for my ex
chair which is what i am sitting in
every time i do the show
i love my ex chair it's by far the most
comfortable and ergonomic chair i've
ever used and honestly it's also
probably the coolest looking piece of
furniture that uh that i own and
certainly that's in the studio what
makes xchair the world's greatest office
chair well maybe it's the patented
dynamic variable lumbar support or the
fact that you can add
lmx technology with four massage options
and the ability to warm or cool your
back at the same time noah no other
office chair can do any of that now is
the perfect time to purchase an ex-chair
why now well because now is the only
time xchair goes on sale all year that's
right only on black friday cyber monday
weekend is the x chair on sale so this
is your time to buy it you deserve a
next chair and uh it's a lot more
comfortable you feel a lot better it's
better for your posture it's better in
every single way so save up to 500 on
xchair four days only on black friday
cyber monday weekend go to
xchairwalsh.com now that's the letter x
chair walsh.com
right now x-chair has a 30-day
money-back guarantee of complete comfort
and you can finance your purchase for as
little as 25 a month go to
xchairwalsh.com and save up to 50 500
again that's exchairwalsh.com
before we get going today i want to
begin with a quick reminder that daily
wire memberships are 50 off right now
this is the last day of the deal you
don't want to miss out on this
opportunity
and uh and i'll be honest with you we
need your support we need your help we
we aren't just making
content at the daily wire we're fighting
and uh we need you to join us in the
fight we're going up against the buying
administration we're turning the tide in
elections we're uncovering major
scandals we're doing all of that with
the help of our subscribers who are very
much a part of the team
and a part of the special thing that
we're building here at the daily wire
and that's why i'm calling on all of my
sweet babies to become daily wire
members also we're creating culture you
know we don't want to just comment on
culture we want to create it and we are
but again we can't do that without you
and as far as creating culture goes i
can tell you that i've been working on
two projects the first i'll announce
tonight on tucker carlson it's a book
that i've been writing for many months
um i've been put my i've put my heart
and soul into it
and i'm really excited to tell you about
it on tucker's show tonight it is i
believe i think it's my magnum opus
really the second project will be
revealed within the next few months i
can't tell you anything about it
except that i'm i'm literally traveling
across the world for it and it's
something that will make it'll make a
lot of people very angry the book i'll
announce tonight will also make a lot of
people very angry but more importantly i
think both will have an impact on the
culture and there these are the kinds of
things we're only able to do
with your support it's an exciting time
the daily wire we've got lots of things
in the works that you aren't expecting
and that will take you by surprise and
if you want to be a part of all that go
to daily wire use code dw50 get your 50
discount today and again make sure to
tune in to tucker carlson tonight now uh
onto the show the uh the truman show was
one of the better films of the 90s it
was also we know now the second to last
good movie that jim carrey would ever
star in that's not really relevant to
our purposes today what is relevant is a
scene about halfway through the movie
featuring ed harris's character
christoph the director and creator of
the giant reality show that jim carrey's
truman has unwittingly been living and
starring in since birth
during an interview with some kind of
news magazine show kristoff has asked
why truman had never up until that point
himself asked any questions about the
nature of his world how is it that he
lived his whole adult life never came to
realize or even suspect that
everything's fake and all of his friends
and family members are actors everything
about his reality is engineered
manufactured
kristoff answers quickly he says we
accept the reality of the world with
which we are presented it's as simple as
that
perhaps one of the truest lines ever
spoken in a hollywood film
and we live in a reality that is nearly
as contrived and concocted as the one
that truman inhabited the only
difference is that the guy walking past
us in the street is not an actor he's
not an agent of this deception he is one
of the deceived just like the rest of us
or most of us
also truman was filmed against his will
or his knowledge that's the case for us
some of the time no doubt but we also
choose to be on camera some of us more
than others as you can see
but the main similarity is that like
truman
reality is presented to us i think the
wording there is important reality
presented
we're not so much encountering reality
or engaging with it certainly not
discovering it
we sit back passively and allow reality
whatever bits of it that our overlords
deem appropriate for viewing
to be presented to us
our reality is not so much
staged like a television production as
it is curated
we view reality mostly through screens
we look at screens more than we look at
anything else we look at screens more
than we look at our children's faces
and inside those screens we find a
version of the world
that someone else
our kristoff and there are many of them
not just one
thinks we ought to be shown
it's not reality it's reality as told by
as curated by cnn
twitter mark zuckerberg corporate media
and so on
they are the directors of our own
personal truman show they present
reality and most people simply accept it
as presented
and that's why for example on this
monday november 29 2021 the major
terrorist attack that occurred on on
sunday november 21st 2021 just a little
over one week ago
has essentially been erased
as far as our reality curators are
concerned it never happened
eight days ago may as well have been 8
000 years ago
nine children are still in the hospital
one child died in the intervening days
bringing the the death total to a six
to go along with the dozens of severe
injuries
it was a horrific attack a massacre
little children and old ladies mowed
down on the street while waving pom-poms
and singing christmas carols
one of the most grotesque and tragic and
infuriating things you will ever see and
you can see it because it was all
documented on multiple cameras from
multiple angles
if the corporate media media our
curators were simply yet cynically
interested in sensationalism and ratings
and nothing more if that's all they
cared about
this story would be one of the only
things they talked about for weeks
but their cynicism is more insidious and
more surreptitious i think than that
their goals are also quite a bit larger
grander
they want to create a certain kind of
reality a reality governed by their
ideological and political needs and this
event a jaw-dropping and certainly
newsworthy event
does not fit into that picture so it's
been in one week
erased
completely
yesterday cnn issued what will likely be
one of its last reports on the subject
and uh it did it in a highly curated way
here's the headline waukesha will hold a
moment of silence today marking one week
since a car drove through a city
christmas parade killing six people and
injuring scores of others
a car
drove through the christmas
parade was it a tesla self-driving car
was it a car from a pixar film with a
mind of its own
outside of those possibilities cars
don't drive
saying a car drove through a parade is
like a sports writer reporting that a
bat hit a home run or a shoe kicked a
field goal
in reality the actual reality not the
curated kind the car was being driven by
a human being and that human being has a
name daryl brooks
he also has a very relevant history of
violent crimes of all types including
sex crimes against children that somehow
had not yet landed him behind bars for
any significant stretch of time and he
had motivations
we may not know his specific motivations
mostly because we can only rely on the
curators to tell us something like that
unless we go to the prison and try to
ask him ourselves
but we can take note of his blm
sympathies his anti-white posts online
his open encouragement of violence
against white people and we could take
all that and reasonably conclude that
this was almost certainly an anti-white
terrorist attack a hate crime
that doesn't fit within the reality that
our curators wish to present and so the
entire event is thrown into a giant hole
and buried
now within a couple of days
um they got us back on track right they
got us back to talking about the kinds
of things that they want us to talk
about in our curated reality
black on white crime essentially does
not exist and is always justified
whenever it does occur
also in this contrived version of the
world
non-white victims are ignored
for racist reasons
the very people who are ignoring the
white victims in waukesha and indeed
ignoring them because they are white
have now gotten back to insisting that
only white victims get attention
a few days ago the daily beast reported
on an hbo documentary called black and
missing
which argues that the media doesn't pay
attention to stories about black missing
persons
the daily beast tweeted um quote can you
name five missing black women director
gita gambier's latest documentary hbo's
black and missing tackles this question
and is unfortunately very timely in
large part because of the gabby potito
case
can you name five missing black women
uh no i can't
but um of course nobody can name five
missing people of any color
nobody can
i guarantee this right now you cannot
name five currently missing white women
or even one currently missing white
woman
you can't
the whole the whole framing of this
thing is completely ridiculous
missing people go missing all of the
time in this country
unfortunately
it can't all be national news almost
none of it ever is
and that's why you can't name them off
the top of your head
however
uh somebody driving their car
intentionally through a christmas parade
and murdering six people including a
child
that is or should be a major national
event
and yet you know who else nobody can
name off the top of their heads the
victims in waukesha
their names by the way were tamara
durand jane kulich lyanna owen virginia
sorensen wilhelm hospital and
eight-year-old jackson sparks
they died terrible and painful deaths
and now the corporate media wants them
to suffer a death of another kind
by erasing their memories completely
and we shouldn't allow that to happen
now let's get to our five headlines
well we're finally in uh what is
actually the advent season not the
christmas season christmas season will
start on christmas but as we get towards
christmas you know here's a gift that
you can give yourself
that is to become a charity mobile
customer because we're a charity mobile
customer you're getting a great service
you're also supporting a company that uh
supports you and supports our fight in
the culture charity mobile is the
pro-life phone company they partner with
you to automatically support the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and they've sent millions of
dollars to charities so far new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone free activation and also
you get a free christmas gift with every
phone from charity mobile while supplies
last um and charity mobile if you're
worried about switching from your old
carrier to charity mobile they make it
very easy to switch you can keep your
existing phone number you may even be
able to keep your existing phone but if
you need a new phone there's no problem
there charity mobile has a variety of
options from basic flip phones and
low-cost smartphones to the latest 5g
phones they've also got my favorite
which is their
new flip phone with parental controls
that allows you to disable
mobile data usage text and pixel
messaging so you can you know make sure
your kids have a phone where they can
keep in touch with you but uh you don't
have to worry about them you know
accessing the internet and all the bad
stuff that can happen there so switch to
charity mobile and support the causes
you care about call them at
or chat with them 1-877-474-3662 at
cherrymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh all right so so
as we get back from thanksgiving hope
you had a good thanksgiving i um and i
hope you had you took time to give
thanks to the men who conquered this
beautiful land because that's what
thanksgiving is really all about and i
also hope that you gorged yourself
sinfully
as per tradition
you know the first settlers to this land
they starved and suffered and died of
dysentery and their teeth rotted out of
their heads and none of them live past
42. and so we give thanks to them by
eating more in a day than they ate in a
year so it's nice i guess in fact we did
we put up on daily wire youtube channel
this uh thanksgiving trivia thing we did
and according to that the average
american eats what was it 4 500 calories
for dinner on thanksgiving
very very impressive and disgusting
um but but it is nice it's just it's not
so nice when you're married to a
full-fledged body shamer and fat shamer
so the day after thanksgiving and we
were at my parents house
i was collapsed on the bed
stomach distended a lumpy lazy
disgusting sweaty mess and my wife came
in and she took a picture and she posted
on the internet you can see you can see
the picture there i mean
absolutely pathetic i've got my shoes on
on the bed
and it's shameful but even more shameful
that my wife would post this
this obscene content to the internet
and you can tell i'm saying something i
can't even speak i'm actually grunting
like get out stop
post it put it right on the internet
that is body shaming that's bullying
fat shaming
everything
um all right that's but that's really if
you didn't if you don't look like that
can i just say if you don't look like
that after thanksgiving you didn't do
thanksgiving right okay can we just
agree on that
all right let's um let's start here
we'll check in with uh thanks with uh
with los angeles first of all couple of
videos
uh and we see these videos
you know multiple times a week
first here's one of an armed robbery
armed robbery this is a a markedly
casual armed robbery at a uh some kind
of buffalo wings joint
in in los angeles you can see it here
let's play this
and you can see the guys walk in
and uh
you know now notice when they go up and
they're gonna there's just two people
sitting there
eating
and they go up and they and a guy pulls
his gun out
and the two victims they don't even look
all that surprised they just kind of
they don't look very surprised they
don't look concerned she just pulls
their watch off gives it to him
this is what it's like living in los
angeles now you just you kind of expect
it
um and then there was another uh here
here's a a uh some gentleman raiding a
woman's car and i think this is also in
los angeles of course
in the middle of the street
and he kind of dives in there
he's going all the way in there taking
his time
and he pulls i think he pulls out some
kind of luggage or something that gets
into his car and he's this is all on
camera
you can even you could see his his
license plate he doesn't care because
because he knows he's not going to be
prosecuted
and he and he throws it in there and
then he drives away
now there are multiple aspects of this
problem that are not discussed in polite
society
one of them is the culture that leads to
this
you know a culture and a state of decay
because of fatherlessness the collapse
of the family
um in the city
okay what we discover and that's really
what it all boils down to that's that's
what lays the bottom of all of this we
can talk about the the policies and
how in california they're not
prosecuting these kinds of crimes and
all of that stuff contributes to it
okay these but those are all branches
that are growing from the tree at the
roots of the tree
is the collapse of the family what we
discovered despite you know blm talking
about wanting to you know abolish the
nuclear family
um and this has been the left's goal for
a long time their stated goal
because the nuclear family is a
patriarchal construct or whatever
but what we've found is that they've
actually done it so this is not that's
not a a goal for the future or anything
like that they have actually they have
succeeded
in certain communities
um at a regional level anyway they've
succeeded in abolishing the nuclear
family and now we get a look at what
that
at the results of that
do you end up with a um
utopia no
and as the the nuclear family is
patriarchal and it victimizes women so
you get rid of the nuclear family do you
end up in a situation where women
are uh you know are are treated better
no quite the opposite
because one thing you notice we'll talk
about some of the
some of the the similarities and some of
the common threads
that kind of where you can stitch all
these events together one thing you
notice is that very often
the victims as was the case in the first
video they watched and i believe the
second the victims are women very often
so you get rid of the the nuclear family
which again in the city the nuclear
family basically doesn't exist at least
80 percent of
kids being raised in the city don't have
fathers in the home
and i'm guessing when you watch these
videos it's like 100 of those people did
not have fathers in the home
and has this worked out well for women
no it certainly has not
um so that's that's one aspect of the
problem that we're not supposed to talk
about
is the uh the collapse of the family and
we're not supposed to talk about it for
many many reasons
uh one is that as we've discussed the
left hates the family to begin with
but also because that puts the onus back
on individuals and they don't they don't
want to do that
because the then the if you're if you're
if we're if we're tying this back to the
collapse of the family
then what we're really saying
is that you know if you're a man
and
you
create children
and then choose to abandon them and not
be there to raise them
then a lot of this is your fault you are
creating this problem
and if we want the problem to go away if
we want to address the problem if we
want to solve it
then that's going to require men
to make babies
and then stay and raise them
but that puts the the onus on the
individual they don't want to do that
because they want individuals to be
helpless
puppets basically
reaching out
to the state to the government to solve
the problem which of course the
government can't do and won't do
um but here's another thing that you
might notice in almost all these videos
uh there's a there's a similarity in the
apparel
you know something they're all wearing
masks in almost every video
now this this is a little bit different
maybe you find some differences in a
place like san francisco
where they don't even need to wear the
mask because they know that there's zero
chance they'll be prosecuted
but if there's any chance of prosecution
um
and at least they still do i guess in
theory they still do a little bit of
that in los angeles in theory
then they're always wearing masks
so maybe you know maybe we draw a
connection there
is is it a coincidence that
starting in about april of 2020
everybody was wearing masks everywhere
and then also around that time is when
robbery looting
and all of that ticked up
so we create a society where it's normal
to wear masks everywhere and now we also
live in a society
where shoplifting and looting and uh
whatever they call flash mob robbery the
word they're using now which is just
which which is looting
we also live in a world where that's
common
along with the masks is that a
coincidence
no of course it's not
um
because it used to be prior to everyone
losing their minds and wearing masks
everywhere
if you were sitting in a you know in a
restaurant
and somebody walks in with a mask on
their face you immediately know what
they're trying to do
that's not the case anymore
so you're giving people anonymity
and you're allowing them to blend in
everybody that if you live in a place
like california anyway everybody that
goes into a restaurant or goes into a
store goes into a drug store i mean they
all look like
like
stagecoach robbers basically with things
around their faces
but this is this is human nature
which is another thing the left doesn't
understand and wants to essentially
abolish
is human nature or at least our
understanding of human nature and part
of human nature is that when you uh
when you bring a bunch of people
together and you make them anonymous
bad things happen
because there's no accountability
people as human beings we need
accountability when you remove
accountability um
the behavior deteriorates that's we see
that we see that on the internet and we
see it now in real life
all right
let's move on to this this is pretty
exciting a new variant has just dropped
it's all the rage all the kids are
talking about it now if you know if
you're getting infected with delta even
delta plus people kind of roll their
eyes it's oh they're awkward about it
it's like if you invite your friends
over to play madden but you have the
madden from 2014 or something it's not
cool
the new joint is uh omicron which it
sounds literally like something from
terminator or maybe like one of those
one of the robot megazords from power
rangers
um when when all of the variants combine
they make omicron
and um
anyway huge coincidence too
this new variant is announced
and there's a big panic and now there
are travel restrictions
and they're talking about new lockdowns
and so on
and they say that this variant infects
young people
specifically
and especially anyway not specifically
but especially
well that's that's a coincidence because
they just started also rolling out the
vaccine for kids 5 to 11. so they start
rolling up the vaccine for kids 5 to 11
and right at the same time there's a new
variant the media is telling us about
where wouldn't you know it it especially
infects young people
huge coincidence there funny how things
work out anyway while the media is
telling us to panic over this uh here's
what the doctors are actually saying
about the new variant this is first from
the telegraph it says the first south
african doctor to alert the authorities
about patients with the omicron variant
has told the telegraph that the symptoms
of the new variant are unusual but mild
dr angelique cotesie said that she was
first alerted to the possibility of a
new variant when patients in her busy
private practice in the capital city
started to come in earlier this month
with cove 19 symptoms
that did not make immediate sense
but she says in fact we have an
interview with her we'll play the clip
of her she says that um that yeah it's
apparently a new variant
it might be more transmissible than
other variants might be we don't
actually know that
but it does appear to be very very mild
let's listen
looking at the mildness of the symptoms
that we are seeing
currently there is no
reason for panicking as we don't see
severely ill patients
i also checked with the hospital some of
the hospitals in my area
and one of the biggest hospitals i only
have one patient currently that's
covered positive on a ventilator and
they don't even know whether it's
covered you know it's delta or whether
it is omicron related we acknowledge
that it might change going forward
but the hype that's been created
currently out there in the media and
worldwide
doesn't correlate
with the clinical
picture
um and it doesn't warrant to just cut us
off
from any traveling and ban south africa
as if we are the villains in the whole
process
should not be like that
okay so it's a cold basically
from what we can tell we're talking
about
according to this doctor
and she's the one who alerted everybody
to this thing
uh it's it's basically it's basically a
cult remember we talked about the
beginning curated reality in our in our
in our own truman show environment
um
that part what you just heard there
that doesn't make it into the picture
because they want us to panic and they
want us to be
uh
perpetually in a state of panic and fear
over this now
i'm i don't claim to be a public health
expert then again most the people who
claim to be public health experts don't
appear to be experts about anything so i
guess i can i could you know i could
just as much sign myself up for that
label as anybody else
and um
so i i could be wrong about this but
maybe correct me if i'm wrong
but if there is a strain of vucovid
which is significantly less
severe
than the other strains
then wouldn't we want that strain to
become the dominant strain
why why try to contain it
now by administration right now is
shutting down travel from from africa
from some african countries like south
africa and other countries
and uh of course he's
needless to say when when trump did
something similar he was called
xenophobic and racist now biden can do
it and and he's allowed to do that again
curated reality so that's he's allowed
to do that
but um
putting that aside for a second putting
aside the hypocrisy the double standard
it would seem to me you know
like sign me up for my for omicron from
what i'm being told
if i got to get one of them i'd i'll
take that one
wouldn't you want if there's a much if
there's a much more mild version even if
it's more transmissible
would seem like that would be the one
you would want to be the dominant strain
in the world
so are we are we trying to contain
the the much more mild version
reportedly
in in order to in order to stick with
the more lethal varieties
is that what's going on doesn't make
sense to me
of course it doesn't make sense to me as
number one a rational logical person and
also as someone who doesn't want people
to die
and uh you know who who sees panic and
fear you know i see all that as
i see all those as bad things and so it
doesn't make sense to me coming from
that perspective
but that's not the perspective shared by
many of our so-called public health
experts
um
covet 19 as i've been saying and i'm
certainly not the only one that's been
saying this
but even as a non-public health expert
it was pretty clear to me early on
that this
is endemic
it's going to be with us forever it's
never going away
we are never going to live in a truly
post-covered world that is a a world
where kobe basically doesn't it's never
going to happen probably
um
so you've got to learn to live your life
with it and if you're going to be scared
into paralysis into a state of paralysis
and convinced to go run into your house
and lock the door hide under the bed
every time the media starts talking
about new variant well then this that's
going to be your whole life it's never
going to stop you're going to live your
whole life this way
it's very clear there are different
strains they're going to continue to be
different strains
and by the way with the with the
creation of new strains the vaccines
probably are you would think maybe
contributing to that
and it's also seasonal
so these things are going to ebb and
flow
and there's always going to be a new
panic as long as we as long as we uh
respond to it the way the media wants us
to
speaking of uh public health experts who
don't appear to be experts in really
anything fauci was on face the nation
over the weekend
and he's out now warning about the
omicron variant and uh you have to take
them seriously he says because if you
would disagree with him if you criticize
him you're criticizing science
he says that directly also says a lot of
other deranged stuff in this clip from
face the nation uh really fauci himself
i think his whole tenure his whole being
can be summed up in this like two minute
clip so let's play this
why do you feel so strongly about that
about staying on the job when you become
i mean you were
personally not just rhetorically
threatened your security your safety
your family yeah how did you deal with
that
i dealt with it by focusing on what my
job is
from the time that i went into medicine
to the right now where i am at my age
my job has been totally
focused on doing what i can
with the talents and the influence i had
to make scientific advances to help
protect the health of the american
public
positive so anybody
he's using the talents he has which
which are which i i still have yet to
notice any to make scientific
advancements
what what scientific advancements has
has
has tony fauci made of course there's no
follow-up
this is not a real journalist this is a
reality curator if she was a real
journalist she would say
well that's that's big news you made a
scientific advancement what was that
that was a he's a bureaucrat he's a
parasite
bureaucrats don't advance anything they
don't discover anything they don't do
anything
he's been living off of the public teat
for uh 40 years
or more
never discovered anything
never achieved anything of note
he has he has been in a position of
overseeing
one public health crisis after another
he's been there to witness it and to
profit off of it
but i'm not aware of any scientific
advancements okay let's keep going
public
so anybody who spends lies and threatens
and all that theater that goes on
with some of the investigations and the
congressional committees and the rand
pauls and all that other nonsense
that's noise margaret that's noise i
know what my job is senator cruz told
the attorney general you should be
prosecuted yeah
i'd have to laugh at that
i should be prosecuted yeah i'm sure he
does what happened on january 6th
senator
do you think we know you're last
you think this is all very funny making
you a scapegoat to deflect of course
president trump of course
you have to be asleep not to figure that
one out well there are a lot of
republican senators uh taking aim
at this right that's okay i'm just going
to do my job
and i'm going to be saving lives and
they're going to be lying
oh really okay
real quick
he's going to be saving how many lives
did he save which which lives were those
that were saved because of because of
tony fauci
also notice how and this has been a case
all along but now he's totally shameless
and open about it he's being openly
political here
to an extent that i don't think we've
seen quite like this now now the the
he's dropped the guard
guards down the mask is off and
everything
um in in in many different ways in fact
the mask is off i mean the the actual
medical mask you notice how these two
they're not really socially distant
they're sitting right there in this
enclosed environment but they don't have
masks on um
and he's being openly political calling
out politicians talking about january
6th
because he's a political animal he's a
bureaucrat all right let's let's uh
finish this up
it seems another layer of danger to play
politics around matters of life and
death right exactly exactly and to me
that's
that's unbelievably bad because all i
want to do is save people's lives and i
mean
anybody who's looking at this carefully
realizes that there's a distinct
anti-science
flavor to this
so if they get up and criticize science
nobody's going to know what they're
talking about
but if they get up and really aim their
bullets at tony fauci well people could
recognize there's a person there so it's
easy to criticize but they're really
criticizing science because i represent
science
that's dangerous to me that's more
dangerous
than the slings and the arrows that get
thrown at me okay and if you damaged
certainly
you were doing so
no you know you know what's dangerous um
dangerous is when a when a bureaucrat or
really any human being any person
presents themselves as the
representative of i represent science i
tell you something right now no real
scientist would ever ever say anything
like that
i represent science
science is a
process
okay science is not an institution it's
certainly not a person
uh it's not a religion
it's not an ideology it's not a
political party
okay it's not a it's not a superhero
it's not a god
science is simply a process
for understanding the physical world
that's all science is
it's a process for understanding the
physical world
so
tony fauci says that he represents he is
the representative on earth of a of the
process of understanding the physical
reality
that's what he's saying
i am the way the truth and the life
i mean the the ego on this guy but can
we be surprised
he has been totally untouchable and
unaccountable as a bureaucrat for
decades
and this is the ego that he's developed
that that's all you need to hear right
there as i said tony fauci his entire
career his tenure everything about him
summed up in that clip
he is a
pure aisle infantile
egotistical
uh
narcissistic
political
self-centered
monster really
i represent science
i i tell you i mean
any any real anyone who forget about
being a scientist anyone who respects
science
which sure i do
science is important it's important to
have a process for understanding the
physical world because it's important
it's important to understand the
physical world
there are a lot of things about kovid
that it's important to understand
um and that people like voucher are
making sure we do not understand in fact
so anyone who respects science should is
it it just makes your
it's nauseating to hear something like
that
i represent science my god
um
and uh one other quick thing here on
this on this governor kathy hokul in
in new york
has just announced this reading for the
new york post that says governor kathy
hulkel signed an executive order friday
to postpone elective hospital surgeries
something that hasn't been done since
the worst of the initial coronavirus
outbreak last year
hokiel said she made the move to deal
with staffing shortages and boost bed
capacity amid an anticipated spike in
new cases and the emergence of the new
omicron variant in south africa so
kathy hawkill the governor of uh of new
york as you know as i've already done
the i told you so thing i don't need to
do it again well i'll do it one more
time i guess uh ever people on the right
celebrating when governor cuomo was was
booted out of office
uh and as i said the person to replace
him will will definitely be a lot worse
than he was
because if she wasn't gonna be worse
they never would have the left never
would have went along with kicking him
out of office in the first place
if there was a chance that he'd be
replaced by some
reasonably competent
even moderate person
no way they'd do it
but they knew they had someone waiting
in the wings who would at least play the
part of a
left-wing um
tyrant
more even more than than cuomo did and
that's exactly what's happened so kathy
hakul has suspended
signed an executive order
saying that if you live in new york
according to her you're not allowed to
get a quote-unquote elective surgery
because of the omicron variant
in south africa which is a cold some
people in south africa have a cold and
so that means that you can't bring your
child to the hospital in new york to get
up to get a surgery a so-called elective
surgery by the way an elective surgery
elective in this case does not mean
unimportant
uh unnecessary
cosmetic it doesn't mean any of those
elective just means that you can you can
schedule it ahead of time
that's basically what it means in
practice most of the time
my point is that there are many elect
so-called elective surgeries
that are life-saving
that are medically necessary
and she's saying you can't get those
and of course the my body my choice
crowd has lined up to defend a
governor's right to tell you that you
are not allowed to get a surgery in the
state
this is also something this principle
something to keep in mind by the way
about uh
you know
the devil you know versus the devil you
don't
because it was also announced today that
the uh the ceo of twitter jack dorsey is
going to be stepping down apparently i
don't know why but he's stepping down i
guess he's made all of his money and
he's tired of of the you know he doesn't
have to go testify in front of congress
anymore and he's got multi billions of
dollars he'll just go off and do what he
wants um investing in crypto or whatever
he wants to do
so he's stepping down and this is
another thing where i'm noticing
some people on the right on social media
on twitter kind of celebrating this
saying ding dong the witch is dead jack
dorsey is gone i i i'm telling you right
now
it's going to be a
governor cuomo it's a cathy hakkiel type
of situation
the person that replaces jack dorsey i
guarantee you will be significantly
worse than he was
the censorship on twitter is about to
get a lot worse
a lot worse
this is the principle with with
institutions in our culture today
they never go right
okay they never they never trend to the
right it never happens
uh it you everything is always shifting
left
and so when there's a turnover in
management when there's a turnover at
the executive level whether it's in
government or in big tech or wherever
it's always going to be to the left
the transition is always going to be to
the left so happen in new york and it's
going to happen
on
twitter as well okay one other thing
before we get to reading the comments i
gotta i gotta play this for you canada's
official indigenous health expert
and that's a position that exists in
canada apparently her name is carrie
barosa and she has always been
very open about her native american
ancestry um she wears you know native
american garb and when she goes out and
she gives talks she she identifies by
the name chief running bear or something
like that
and she talks a lot about the racism
that she's experienced so she's very
open about it in fact here are some
clips of her on uh a couple clubs here
she's on some news programs and then she
also did a ted talk
where she's talking about indigenous
issues let's watch that
unfortunately
many people that access healthcare feel
stigmatized they
will might experience racism or
prejudice and whether it's perceived or
it's real when you're experiencing it
it's very real have you experienced it i
have i have experienced it my
great-grandmother was clinkid she
married an immigrant
they moved from uh the far northern bc
into saskatchewan and they had a family
greetings
my name is morning starbear
i'm just going to say it i'm emotional
so
i'm bear clan i'm a nishnabe meti from
treaty for territory and i want to
acknowledge the territory that i'm in
3d6 territory
home to the kree peoples and
homeland of the metis nation
i also want to acknowledge my ancestors
who are clearly here with me
that's uh that that's tough you know
that she
wow
she's she getting really really
emotional about her native american
ancestry uh uh morning sorry not chief
running bear she's a uh more more what
was it morning star
morning star bear it's not funny i mean
that's that's her that's her ancestral
name who am i to make fun of not making
fun of it
um
but now let's let's get an update on
this story this is from the new york
post it says a canadian medical
researcher who rose to become the
nation's top voice on indigenous
healthcare has been ousted from her
government job and her university
professorship after suspicious
colleagues investigated her increasingly
fanciful claims of native american
heritage and learned she was a fraud
uh so it turns out they did a they they
looked into this and they did a lot of
research about it
and uh it turns out that she does not
she's not a native american so she
pulled an elizabeth warren but unlike
elizabeth warren elizabeth warren got
the exception and uh and she got to get
out of jail free card she got she got
the get out of jail
free card for her appropriation and
there's only one of them and she got it
so carrie barosa morningstar bear is not
going to get it it turns out
they did they traced her family tree
i don't know how exactly they did this i
don't know if they obtained a dna sample
against her will or something
they took from a you know a drinking
glass that she was drinking and took the
dna sample i don't know what they did
but they traced her her family heritage
and they discovered that she is really
descended from immigrant farmers from
russia and poland in czechoslovakia
so
two things about this
one is again we have more proof
that the mainstream narrative of
systemic oppression
is false
the
the version of systemic oppression the
the narrative
of systemic oppression that we get from
the reality curators is completely false
because if native if indigenous people
were persecuted if they were repressed
then and you were not in the oppressed
group
you in fact were in the you were in the
dominant group allegedly you would not
pretend to be in the oppressed group
because it would not benefit you
these people
do this because they know it will
benefit them and it does
until until the ruse is discovered
but also um
you would think if you're trying to
score points off of the suffering of
your ancestors
which you shouldn't be able to do
okay in a in a in a normal and a sane
society you wouldn't be able to do that
the fact that your ancestors suffered
should that shouldn't do anything for
you because it's not your suffering
but if you were if that's what this was
about
then you would think that your ancestors
being polish farmers
you wouldn't why not just go with that
why not go with the truth polish farmers
i mean these were probably people who
lived pretty difficult lives
i don't know about you i wouldn't i
wouldn't want to trace i wouldn't want
to trade places with a polish farmer
from the 19th century
but they don't count that's why because
their suffering doesn't count because
they were basically white and so uh
that's why that doesn't count
and then but the second thing we we can
take from this or the question we can
ask i guess is um
really more of a rhetorical question
because i know the answer but
of course why can't she identify as a
native american
why is this not a valid thing
she feels connected with native american
culture
she identifies with it
this is her truth
um she has transitioned
okay she's she's living that truth
doesn't harm anybody else
this is what we're always told about
trans people right that's what all we're
always well if somebody wants to live
that way doesn't harm you what
difference does it make
if this is what they want to identify
what does it matter
same thing should apply here
only as i always say even more so
the person claiming to be trans-racial
or trans-ethnic
their
their claim is more credible
is more defensible it's still not
credible and not defensible but it's
more credible and more defensible
than the transgender claim
because we know that races and
ethnicities are in fact fluid
okay they they combine and culture is
also very fluid
it changes over time it has different
influences and so on
you can actually be a mix of different
races and different ethnicities i mean
almost everybody is
whereas with sex that's not the case
you're either male or female
so you would think
that this would be a perfectly valid
thing that a person could do uh but but
they can't because it doesn't fit with
the narrative and i know that you know
another thing you hear from the right a
lot is that this is part of the slippery
slope and so uh right now we've got the
transgender thing and eventually we'll
be in a spot where uh we're expected to
accept transracial also
but no because this is not this is not a
slippery slope situation
on the slippery slope the idea is that
the next thing is always more outrageous
and more absurd and more grotesque right
but transracial is actually farther up
on on the slope
because it's more again more defensible
and more credible
we've we we have leapfrogged over
transracial we're not doing that
you know what the only problem with the
slippery slope idea
um
is that
it
there's
it doesn't always follow a logical
progression
because it's not like we're sliding down
this slope
by happenstance
we are being steered down it's by
cultural forces
and so there are certain things that you
would think would be part of the logical
progression that they kind of steer
around because they don't want to do
that one the transracial thing we're not
doing
all right let's get now to our comment
section
as we get into the comments good time to
remind you that we do now have a
merchandise store at the daily wire you
go to dailywire.com go to the shop
tab right there at the top very easy to
find
and then you can look at all the
merchandise but the first place you
should go of course is to the it's to my
store
and there's a lot of great stuff there a
lot of great merch my wife told me to
stop calling it merch so i said okay
i'll call it swag now from now on that's
what i'll call it even more annoying a
lot of great swag there someone pointed
out that and i think this is true it's
pretty great that um you look at all the
different merchandise stores on daily
wire from you know the other the other
personalities
and uh they've all got books and you
know like really serious things and
mine's just a meme store that's all it's
just a bunch of but just a bunch of
memes about pandas and shopping carts
and as it should be i suppose
all right let's get uh to some of the
comments here this is from
taimaishu says waka shows the perfect
example of why guns are not the problem
you can't stop a suicidal madman who
wants to hurt innocent people well
you're exactly right the only
qualm maybe here is that i i don't know
if mad man
he's a monster
and a murderer
uh but
you know and i know we say mad man kind
of colloquially but
you know that kind of lets people off
the hook the assumption that this person
was insane and didn't know it didn't
know if he's actually a madman that
means he didn't know what he was doing
now to my mind that still means you you
need to send this person you need to
lock this person away for the rest of
their lives but you are taking some of
the moral onus off of them i don't think
that's the case at all i think he did
this intentionally knew exactly what he
was doing he had reasons for doing it
just we're not being told any of that
but as far as the gun thing yeah you're
exactly right if somebody
decides
that they want to go out and kill people
there is
no tool you can take away from them that
will prevent them from carrying out the
plan to kill people
just you can't do it
the reason why you know the vast
majority of people on earth
have never killed anybody
and
luckily right
why haven't they killed anybody is it
because they didn't have the means to do
it no it's because the vast majority of
people have never wanted to kill anybody
that's why they haven't done it
now when you put it that way it it's
it's a it's a little bit less it's kind
of it's not very reassuring because then
what you're saying is what the only
thing stopping people from killing each
other is they don't want to
what you're saying is that the moment
someone decides they want to they're
just going to go yeah basically
um
does that mean that we just have to
accept that reality
and do nothing to protect ourselves no
what it means though is that law is put
in place ahead of time to stop people
from carrying out murders are most often
not very effective
in order to protect yourself you can't
rely on the law you have to you have to
rely on yourself
because when the guy comes with the gun
or the car whatever his tool of choice
is
the law is not a physical barrier that's
going to stop him
there are physical ways you can stop
them and that's one of those is to carry
a gun
old sloppy says dear matt love the show
love the sweet baby gang disappointed
that there is no sbg onesie for babies
how is my seven month old daughter going
to represent her favorite dw host missed
opportunity
well the the store is by no means
finished okay i agree with you we do
need that to we want a doctrine this is
a cult of course a sweet baby gang we
want to indoctrinate people very very
young um and uh so we're going to make
sure we are going to get that we're
going to get all we need a lot of stuff
but if you want to make sure
that we get new merchandise
to the shop then the best thing you can
do is buy the merchandise that's
currently there
and then and then i can convince them to
put more merchandise in
um let's see
emilia says i realize matt doesn't care
but uh broccoli has a chemical reaction
to being cut as a defense mechanism this
makes it more bitter his point on the
lack of empathy for plants as we cut
them actually is a fair point okay this
is a comment from we put up our
thanksgiving video of um
me responding to some am i the a-hole
quandaries from reddit
and uh yeah there was there was someone
who was a vegan on thanksgiving and like
i made the point that you know if you're
look
you eat plants plants are living
creatures also
that have their own hopes and dreams and
and and feelings maybe
as amelia points out i didn't even know
that
so when you eat broccoli i don't know if
this is true or not but i'm going to go
with this because it works it confirms
my priors
when you eat broccoli broccoli if you
enjoy it and i do enjoy broccoli
um
you are actually
tasting the pain of that living creature
that's what you're enjoying vegans how
do you feel now another reminder as we
talked about at the top today is the
last day to get 50 off your daily wire
memberships if you have not yet become a
daily wire member you're missing out on
all the great stuff uh that you get with
a membership like our brand new comedy
series truth yeller hosted by comedian
and podcaster adam carolla in each
episode of truth yeller adam invites a
celebrity guest to join him for an
evening of stand-up comedy improv and
interview all in front of a masculist
live audience uh the very first episode
dropped yesterday starring none other
than jay leno and uh the show i watched
it myself it's a lot of fun it's very
funny and uh just one one other perk a
really great perk that you get with a
daily wire membership but more than that
you're helping us build something
important when you become a daily wire
member your membership allowed us to
help gina carano who was fired from
disney simply because they didn't like
her political point of view now we're
making a movie with gina it's coming out
next year and it's going to be fantastic
terror on the prairie i'm looking
forward to that i'm a big western fan
myself so i could be happier that we're
making a western and then just as big
you're helping us fight the biden
administration's vaccine mandate all
across the country um so we need your
help once more use code dw50 for 50 off
this cyber monday we really appreciate
all that you do for us you make all this
possible keep making it possible become
a member today go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code dw50 for 50 off
your new daily wire membership you won't
regret it now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so today i'm afraid we have to cancel
gop congresswoman lauren bobert um i was
just giving bobert props on this show a
week or two ago after she stood up to
the democrats and their fake outrage
over paul gosar's supposedly offensive
anime meme you may remember during the
hearings to censor
gosar bobert took the opportunity to
stand on the house floor and remind the
public that many democrats had engaged
in activities far more outrageous and
dangerous than posting memes
she observed as she observed eric
swalwell congressman and prominent
public farter was romantically involved
with a chinese spy named fangfeng that's
just one example and it was a good
moment for bobart
she deserved credit for it and i gave
her credit
but now the tables have turned
unfortunately
the congresswoman was herself the target
of immense and immensely fake democrat
outrage late last week after a video
went viral showing bobert at an event in
her district
making an edgy joke about ilhan omar
here it is
actually i have an ill-hand story for
you
so uh the other night on the house floor
was not the my first jihad squad moment
uh so
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers and he and i are we're
leaving the capitol we're going back to
my office and we get an elevator and i
see a capitol police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see fret all over his
face and he's reaching and i'm like
i can't the door's shutting like i can't
i can't open it like what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
on omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
so we only had one floor to go and he
was like uh did i say it why not i
looked over and i said oh look the jihad
squad decided to show up for work today
don't worry it's just her staffers on
twitter the talk for her she's not tough
in person she doesn't yes
so
there's a little bit of interactions
with these folks
well that got about the reception you
would expect uh or should expect the
media desperate to move on from sort of
pretending to care about a terrorist
attack at a christmas parade that killed
six people had found the perfect
diversion after all why should anyone
worry about six dead people including a
child when a liberal muslim woman just
got her feelings hurt
as we've learned the feelings of a
member of a victim class always outweigh
even the physical suffering and death of
a non-victim-class person accordingly
the media and democrat party leapt into
action tissues in hand tears streaming
down their face condemning the joke with
righteous fury omar herself was in front
of the line ecstatic
for the opportunity to be the lead
victim in her party for a few days she
spoke out against bobert with with uh
with what some might describe as
explosive rage tweeting saying i'm a
suicide bomber is no laughing matter gop
leader and speaker pelosi need to take
appropriate action normalizing this
bigotry not only endangers my life but
the lives of all muslims anti-muslim
bigotry has no place in congress
endangers her life yes a joke
endangers her life
she's lucky to survive to have survived
the joke our hospitals and morgues are
riddled with the bodies of joke victims
we can only thank god that she was not
among them aside from omar many other
democrats joined the outraged circus and
as always a parade of republican patsies
were willing to join in as well
noted gop [ __ ] asa hutchinson was pulled
out of his box in the basement and
trotted in front of cameras on cnn to
offer his own condemnations here's that
house republican leader kevin mccarthy
finally released a statement about this
yesterday he said he called beau bert
encouraged her to meet with omar but
notably did not publicly condemn what
she said and he's actually never
publicly condemned congressman paul
gosar for tweeting an animated video of
himself killing a democratic
congresswoman so do you think mccarthy
should be publicly condemning this kind
of behavior
i do i think whenever even in our own
caucus our own members if they go the
wrong direction i mean it has to be
called out
it has to be dealt with particularly
whenever it is breaching the civility
whenever it is crossing the line in
terms of violence or
or or increasing the divide in our
country so
one of the things that's really
important to us in the future is
increasing the civil debate
and civil discourse and we've got to
look for ways that we can bring people
together and not divide and certainly
along racial lines
well at least they uh let him take the
ball gag out of his mouth first and
frankly you have to give hutchinson some
credit he's in favor of castrating
little boys so at least he was
apparently willing to undergo the
procedure himself first
anyway it only it only uh took a couple
of days of this kind of bad faith phony
self-righteous outrage for bobert to
make the catastrophic and yet totally
routine mistake of publicly apologizing
on friday she released this statement
she says i apologize to anyone in the
muslim community i offended with my
comment about representative omar i've
reached out to her office to speak with
her directly there are plenty of policy
differences to focus on without this
unnecessary distraction
no no no
i say again no
it is a terrible idea to publicly
apologize it's always a terrible idea to
publicly apologize and let's review the
reasons once more first
whether you were wrong or right in your
words or your actions whether you were
justified or unjustified whether you
acted appropriately or inappropriately
you should never apologize to the
left-wing outrage mob ever under any
circumstance
like we just talked about remember that
these people all of them were
significantly more angry and upset over
a joke about ilhan omar than they were
about a bunch of elderly people and
children being massacred by a blm
militant in wisconsin what does that
tell you it tells you that their outrage
is fake fraudulent manipulative the
worst thing you can do with a
manipulative person is to give them what
they want my kids know this they know
that if they want something from me
and they try to manipulate me as kids
try to do sometimes they won't get it
even if i would have otherwise given it
to them even if there's nothing
necessarily wrong with what they
requested
if they try to manipulate to get it if
they lie if they use any kind of
emotional blackmail in their childlike
way
they will not get what they want
now apply that standard on a larger
scale we live in a society overrun by
manipulative emotional blackmailing
phonies and liars who do not have the
excuse of being seven years old
they should never get what they want
your submission and humiliation and
compliance is what fuels them your
apology is like a slab of meat
thrown into a pack of rabid dogs it's
not going to call them off it won't make
them go away
no lesson will be learned other than
this tactic works we should do it more
often
so never apologize second by apologizing
you admit guilt you affirm the version
of yourself that your critics have
presented this is a perfect example so
bobert apologized to the muslim
community which affirms and confirms
that this was an anti-muslim
quote-unquote islamophobic content
comment but it wasn't
bober didn't say this about omar because
she's muslim she said it because omar
openly sympathizes with terrorists
she laughs about terror attacks she
downplays 9 11. by all appearances she
actually does seem to support
terroristic violence carried out by
islamic fundamentalists
this is the impression that she has
given us by her own words and her own
behavior
that's where the joke comes from that's
why she deserves the joke she brings it
on herself
not all muslims support terrorism this
one does
so you let her off the hook by
apologizing to the whole muslim
community
third if you're going to be in this game
as a conservative
if you're going to have a platform and
use it to say edgy things
then you need to be smart
you need to think one step ahead at
least one step ahead
so i have no problem with anybody on the
right whether they're in congress or not
being provocative and offensive
how could i i mean look at me
but if you're going to go down that road
you need to be smart enough to know
where it leads if you're going to say
the provocative thing then you have to
think about what the reaction will be
and how you will respond to that
reaction think about this ahead of time
this could have been a win for beau bert
if she'd made the joke waited for the
totally predictable blow up pun intended
and then used that as a platform to call
attention to omar's own comments about
terrorism and 9 11 and so forth she
could have said well you know what this
no no i'm not gonna let her pawn this
off on on muslims i didn't this wasn't
about muslims this was here's what you
want to know why i said this here's why
i said it
and i'll say it again
so you're using the here's with the
outrage the advantage is that they're
they are focusing the attention on you
they are they are they are increasing
the visibility of your platform
so use that visibility
for something
if if you weren't planning on doing that
then why did you say the thing to begin
with
see that's the chess match but you lose
the match if you make one move and the
other side makes their move and then you
get up from the table screaming in fear
you have to know what they're going to
do and what you're going to do in
response to it if you're just being
provocative with no plan and nothing
underneath it and without the spine to
stick by your words and turn the outrage
back against itself
then please do us a favor and keep it
milk toast keep it safe and
uncontroversial
the controversial stuff does no one any
good if you aren't going to be both
smart and firm when push comes to shove
and that is why i have to say lauren
bobert today
is cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
make sure tune in to tucker tonight
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
the experts drop a new covid variant
ilhan omar gets a republican congressman
to apologize over a joke and norway
turns santa gay check it out on the
michael knowles show